it is common for people with high blood
pressure and abnormal lipid levels to
also have type 2 diabetes
this video will show how having all of
these conditions can affect your health
and what you can do to reduce your risk
of type 2 diabetes
if you have high blood pressure it means
the force of the blood pushing on the
walls of your blood vessels is too high
your heart has to work harder when your
blood pressure is high
some people with high blood pressure
develop type 2 diabetes
if you have abnormal levels of lipids in
your blood it may mean you have too much
ldl cholesterol also known as bad
cholesterol
or it may mean that you don't have
enough hdl cholesterol also known as
good cholesterol
or your triglyceride level also known as
the fat in the blood may be too high you
may have more than one of these lipid
abnormalities at the same time
people with abnormal lipid levels have a
higher rate of type 2 diabetes
type 2 diabetes is a condition where
your blood glucose
or blood sugar is elevated
over time high blood sugar can damage
the blood vessels of your heart and
other organs leading to other health
problems
having high blood pressure abnormal
lipid levels and type 2 diabetes can
affect you in many ways
you will have a higher risk for other
serious health problems such as a
coronary artery disease
heart attack stroke and even death
you may need help taking care of
yourself
you may also need to take more
medications
living with these conditions may cause
depression
the good news is that there are things
you can do to help lower your risk of
developing type 2 diabetes
for example you may need to make changes
to your lifestyle
if you smoke get the help you need to
quit
maintain or get to a healthy weight
follow a healthy eating plan including
low fat and low sodium foods
and work with your health care provider
to determine the right amount of
physical activity for you
make sure you work with your health care
provider to control your blood pressure
and lipid levels
this includes taking medications as
prescribed by your health care provider
following the treatment plan you and
your health care provider discussed will
help you feel better and reduce your
risk of getting type 2 diabetes
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or nml where
you can download this animation and
thousands of medical images and videos
created by nucleus medical media to
apply for a free 30-day trial click on
the link in the description
you